echemos un vistazo a la reacción general
para la sustitución electro física
aromática empezaremos con benceno y lo
haremos reaccionar con una molécula que
contiene un electro filo lo que ocurrirá
es que vamos a sustituir el electro filo
por un protón en nuestro benceno por eso
se llama sustitución electro física
sustituimos un protón por un electro
filo y es una sustitución electro física
aromática porque haremos cambios en el
anillo aromático durante nuestro
mecanismo una sustitución electro física
aromática necesita un catalizador para
poder generar nuestro electro filo
podemos ver que el catalizador reacciona
para producir un electro filo cargado
positivamente recuerden el electro filo
quiere decir
de electrones también formamos un
compuesto catalítico entonces una vez
que hemos formado a nuestro electro filo
veamos con más detalle lo que ocurre en
la sustitución electro física aromática
empezamos con nuestro benceno
y aquí tenemos uno de los hidrógenos
saliendo del anillo podría ser
cualquiera de los seis y formamos
nuestro electro filo con ayuda del
catalizador cargas negativas se sienten
atraídas a las cargas positivas
entonces los electrones y en el benceno
funcionarán como un núcleo filo y
ocurrirá un ataque núcleo físico
formarán un enlace covalente con nuestro
electro filo dibujemos el resultado
estos electrones que no participan el
hidrógeno permanece ahí y podemos
mostrar al electro filo que se adiciona
a cualquiera de estos dos carbonos como
aquí tenemos al hidrógeno hacia arriba
pongamos el electro filo aquí
y ahí está resaltemos los electrones
estos electrones son los que funcionan
como núcleo filo y forman este enlace
pero le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono
entonces nos queda con una carga formal
positiva y podemos dibujar una posible
estructura de resonancia digamos que
estos electrones pi se moverán hacia acá
dibujemos lo que sucedió ya teníamos
estos electrones pi también tenemos al
hidrógeno y a nuestro electro filo ahora
los electrones se movieron a esta
posición déjenme resaltar los en
amarillo estos electrones se movieron
aquí
y esta vez le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono entonces ahora tiene una carga
forma al positiva y podemos dibujar otra
estructura de resonancia ahora estos
electrones se moverán hacia acá
dibujemos lo que nos quedaría
nuevamente tenemos al hidrógeno y a
nuestro electro filo y ahora estos
electrones se movieron aquí resaltemos
los electrones
esta vez los pondré de color azul estos
electrones se movieron hacia acá y ahora
le quitamos un enlace a este carbono
entonces tiene una carga formal positiva
estas son nuestras estructuras de
resonancia y recuerden que el carbó
catión es en realidad un híbrido de
todas las estructuras de resonancia a
ese híbrido se le llama complejo sigma
así que tenemos una carga formal
positiva deslocalizada en 3 carbonos de
nuestro complejo sigma para el siguiente
paso en el mecanismo redd dibujaré
nuevamente la primera estructura de
resonancia
aquí tenemos al hidrógeno
y a nuestro electro filo que ya está
unido al anillo y tenemos una carga
formal positiva en este carbono
recuerden que el catalizador ha formado
un complejo y lo representamos de esta
manera así indicamos que algo está unido
al catalizador regresemos un poco cuando
generamos el electro filo también se
generó el complejo catalítico podríamos
pensar en esto funcionando como una base
es decir aceptar a un protón entonces
estos electrones toman a este protón
dejando a estos electrones que se
moverán hacia el benceno deshaciéndose
de la carga formal positiva
dibujemos el resultado tenemos nuestro
anillo aromático
y unido al anillo tenemos a nuestro
electro filo
así que el electro fi lo ha sustituido
completamente al protón sigamos a los
electrones estos electrones en rojo son
estos electrones que se mueven para
reformar nuestro anillo aromático así
que la des protón acción del complejo
sigma restablece el anillo aromático y
nos queda un producto estable otro
producto en el que podemos pensar es
este que está unido al protón entonces
tenemos la y unida al protón y podemos
resaltar los electrones digamos que
estos electrones ahora son estos de aquí
al quitarle esos electrones al
catalizador se regenera es decir el
catalizador queda libre para poder
reutilizarlo en otra reacción entonces
es
es nuestro mecanismo general para la
sustitución electro física aromática las
reacciones que veremos más adelante
seguirán este mecanismo general